DNC seems to have raised 140 million to
the rnc's 87 million yeah they
embarrassing that's more with Joe Biden
says Allied groups uh so it might be
just more than just DNC wow dude the RNC
entered 2024 with eight with only $8
million that's nuts that's
insane raised million the first
something like that that's nuts man how
much they they entered the year with 8
million in cash and now they've got how
much 87 I don't think this article has
their total uh rate okay here we go they
raised 87.2 million in 2023 ending the
year with 8 million left in the bank wow
wow the DNC raised 119 million with 21
million cash on hand and then I'm not
finding turning points numbers exactly
but uh their revenue of 2022 was 55
million that was their revenue 55
million 55 million they're starting to
repl this is what I was wondering
they're starting to replace the RNC yeah
why would anyone donate to the RNC at
all